hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now we
have a number of uninvited guests on our
sub but we've got another problem
there's the active lava zone yet to
explore it we are not near it and big
boy over there seems to be pretty peeved
that I left our fight mid-fight and so
I'm just gonna have to come back
eventually and beat the [ __ ] out of them
just a little bit more than I already
have
but I'm lost where am i right now I
can't see anything in front of oh hey
hidey-hidey-ho neighbor I'm gonna go
somewhere else because brick you I'm
gonna go find me an enact or an active
lava zone so the active lava zone is
somewhere down in a crevasse deep in the
bosom of the world maybe even this one
in fact it looks like it's definitely
this one this seems like a crevasse type
crevasse filled with lava plumes of some
sort I was apparently right next to it
who this hee hee dee dee dee ho this
looks scary as fudge oh Bonanza mo Manzi
this where I'm supposed to be I see a
little bit of hold air I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to fit though mr.
Fester would but something tells me I
don't want to take mr. Pfister out on my
own just to go in that hole ok here we
go I shouldn't take this down there you
know what I'm not gonna do that I I'm
gonna I'm gonna go against my better
judgment and I'm gonna go down in this
hole by myself can i repair you from
here do you need repairing I can't even
remember ok but I bet the depth thing is
broken again so I got to pop that out
and put that back in EXO depth warning
yeah I know cuz you're stupid you're
stupid
alright fine I'm gonna save and then
I'll compound repair as best I can I
don't know if it's gonna work but all of
us I got revenue ski ah crush steps I
know where where are you where are you
where to go hey there you're
come here gimme you off that bad boy out
Bob that bad boy and that's all it takes
hop in wait what's the what's repair at
right now no no such luck
ah so indestructible is it okay it's
full alrighty then
why goodbye big bucks Barry I'll
remember you in the terrifying darkness
God last time I was here was long before
any of this was ever finished nothing in
here was textured besides the most basic
lava oh my god that ain't good alright I
have no food I have no water why am I
gonna go down here cuz I'm an idiot
that's why do i water no pie dude
I should go be quarter I'm gonna go make
water real quick I'll be back
uh huh problem I have no salt you can't
make water without salt
okay that's gonna officially gonna suck
oh you know what I'm gonna try this cuz
uh ah I think we can fit I'm pretty sure
we can fit down here I think we can fit
yeah oh yeah you're good you're good
you're good you're good you're good
you're good you're good made it okay I
made it I think we're a little tilted
but I think we still made it hello hi
underwater creatures oh that's what they
mean by active Hey
how you doing there buddy hey still
being an [ __ ] great you keep doing
that over there and I'll be over here
building my base right in your face and
then I'm gonna [ __ ] you up all over the
place he seems pretty pissed about that
challenge I don't know if he's gonna
come up the wall I see so you're
guarding it aren't you oh you're
guarding it I'm just about at the limit
of my Cyclops but I'm still gonna come
down here and [ __ ] your [ __ ] oh you want
to Ram
huh I'll mess you up buddy huh yeah
don't come near me
hey I'm scared but that doesn't mean
that I'm not dangerous just because you
can kick my ass in an instant doesn't
mean that you should okay take the moral
high ground you big [ __ ] baby
I find that and bother nobody but for
some reason it's a lot more clear down
here than it was up there ooh boy
okay then loading hurry there well there
it is that's the thing that is
legitimately the thing now you can't go
in it yet and that's the big tragedy of
it all you can't go in this thing but
it's all here it exists and it has some
sort of front door there but I still
don't think you can go in that they can
you can you no no no no you wouldn't be
able to go in there what no no maybe in
that front alcove area I'm gonna take
mr. Fisher out and see what's wood over
here but I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
it ain't no kind of nothing okay yeah so
it's here but you can't go in it there's
no console to put in the big glowing
blue artifact here as much as I want to
there's just no way to get in there at
the moment so I'm just gonna have to
make do and oh the hell then what the
hell is any of this anyway what are you
slow tting little boxes here it's just
really quiet down here it's just that's
what makes it really disturbing hey you
I marry you I want a better you lava I
cool lava ring gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme
ah the boomerang I know I'm dying right
now but you don't need to worry about
that I'm fine
lot of the ring when I can't get some
water out of this ish my guys going to
be a noisy neighbor keeping me up at
night you may be asking yourself why
markiplier why would you make a base
down here
I saved that why not usually my answer
to pretty much any question directed
towards me when it questions my
capability as a leader and a pioneer and
an explorer alright so I don't know how
lava is gonna make this more moist but
I'm gonna give it a go let's cook you up
I suppose alright I got me some new
creatures God that guy is going to keep
complaining til the day goes away
hell yeah what kind of worked worked
well enough oh god what I need so I
don't have water I don't have pretty
much anything but what I do have is
knowledge and knowledge is power in case
you didn't know so what I'm gonna do is
I've been told by some people hey Lester
come on with me you're ain't bothers me
that much but I've been told by some
people there is titanium down here which
brings me in a nice segue to the
comments for this video so thank you
everybody so much for leaving so many
nice comments in the last one here is
the words from Seth Begley which really
reinforced my idea of making a base down
here because I think it'd be frickin
awesome Seth said mark you remember the
tiger plant seeds you should try to put
them outside your lava base you're going
to make so you can ward off that sea
dragon and that's pretty damn nice
because there's at sea during hey look
it's old mark and then I said you darn
sea dragon kid get off my property and
then Tiger plants furious machine-gun
noises like I just imagined that and the
way they wrote it out was like if the
sea dragon ever came by then my my tiger
plants would just and hopefully killed a
sea dragon which I don't know if it's
even possible but tym said the sea
dragon can be killed it has hit points
which means that it can eventually be
killed technically when people kill
Reaper leviathans and what
I had to do on the stream I was very
close doing it but then I gave up before
I actually had a chance to a k1 oh man
that Lester got knocked the [ __ ] out of
here okay but what happened was a sea
dragon takes a hundred and fifty eight
knife swings to kill it which is a lot I
broke two knives just trying to do that
myself but if I had gotten a few more on
may have actually done a dent in it
we're turning up it would have been
worth it other than just bragging rights
but I could have done that also mr.
Samuel rue said hey mark they're going
to make the Cyclops destructible again
which might make you want to rethink
your kamikaze tactics for your Cyclops
against dragon and I say native that is
only one way I know how to play and
that's by ramen whatever I have in my
near vicinity into the closest monster
and by monster I mean literally anything
in here is a monster compared to make
and then pinecone said mark what if the
entire planet is a sea dragon swimming
in the sea of space I think you may have
think of you may have puffed a little
too deeply from the split that is
subnautica if that made any sense at all
you may have you may have quashed
quaffed a little too greedily on the on
the on the joint - that is subnautica so
you're just too high right now so calm
down wait no this is the way I came well
then what was the other way wait a
minute I'm confused here so if this is
the way I came then what's over there
then wouldn't happen to be two ways into
the active lava zone we're there does
that be super weird I mean it's kind of
like the kind of like The Lost River
with all the rivers of horrible chlorine
gas that are just coating the bottom
floor but this time it's lava melt your
face off style lava all your skin go
gone lava which I don't know which ones
worse one melts your skin off with gas
one melts your skin off with horrible
searing pain actually they both do that
but
God wait there was a way down here hey
beep-beep I'm a Jeep baby [ __ ] you oh
yeah try yeah try try try it did you try
it did it work no [ __ ] off [ __ ] I'm
gonna hack it oh hey you guilted up out
of nowhere where am I now
Oh am i back am i back well [ __ ] well
sure
alright well apparently I got back into
the active lava zone don't know I'm I'm
out we're here but now this segues into
what I want to do next because there
wasn't anything else down there to do
literally it's just that zone and that
building that you can't go into so in
respect for that idea I'm gonna go back
and then starts the preparation sale
because I I have a full whole interest
in making sure that that place down
there is my own we will either
cohabitate there the sea dragon and I or
he will discover that there can be only
one monster in this sea and it
crash-landed on a ship 59 episodes ago I
think I might be like a long time ago
the only way I knew how to get into the
active lava zone where the lava zone in
general was through a weird hole in the
middle of nowhere there was this weird
hole right out by the dunes on the other
side of the mushroom forest I don't know
where I am now because I apparently hit
a wall okay I know on a navigate hey you
got back off I know what I'm doing do
you think you wanna drive on you want to
drive okay go ahead will do will do
twitch plays subnautica you guys can
control my sub for me
don't worry I'll figure out a way to do
it I'll just map all the keys to my
controller he'll be good hope I can
still go up No
do that where the heck II what this
can't be nothing in it am I going ah I
see more left I did the opposite of that
I continued to go right and straight
into a blank wall
I should have been gone that way or
maybe there's no where the Frick am I so
I did come back so there were two
entrances to that active lava zone one a
hole in the VAT in the ground with a
crack in it and the other just kind of
like a straight down shot Oh a dragon
all right I'll be back all right I'm
going to make the arduous journey
without hitting anything back to where I
need to go and you sack of [ __ ] you you
I'm gonna come back for you don't even
think about it I'm out of your league
anyway you're not attractive enough yeah
I don't think you're pretty cuz you're
not now it's pretty of me anyway
I mean I've met the lights are nice but
you you need to take it down a notch get
that ego in check before I check it for
you all right time to clean off the crud
actually you know what they can see the
light of day maybe they've earned it
maybe they've earned a ride to the
surface
maybe they'll explode from the pressure
differential that'll actually happen if
you take creatures from like the very
deepest parts of our ocean in real life
and you bring them up top they're used
to such crushing pressures their bodies
are built that way there and if you
don't give them time to adjust the
equilibrium not the babies you're able
to survive anyway but they will
literally explode just because the
pressure is too great it's like if
you've ever seen a video of us going
down wave in a sub or something and then
they'll put out like a Styrofoam cup out
into the water
it'll be crushed instantly by the water
pressure I mean that's why all of these
things fail because the water pressure
is too high for the structural integrity
of these ships to sustain itself and
therefore
if you were to do the reverse okay bye
have fun back flipping into next year
all right through that that's cool too
but if you were to bring them up they
would pop and that means no good god I
bent down in the lava zone for so long I
forgot what the rest of subnautica
looked like ah I mean of all the zones
probably the blood kelp zone is probably
one of my least explored that's
guaranteed 100% guaranteed it's one of
the lower end ones yeah just cuz I don't
want to be here it's so creepy
Oh Karen don't you know I'm in the
normal ocean now I can't be hurt by any
means Siam's oh my god good day
oh is it honestly day am i really free
am I actually free could I honestly be
free free from the torment free from the
shackles of the Lavar what is this
bright light ah I can't believe yeah ah
whoa we flew I okay ants produce-- oh my
god the Sun I can see it again ah oh my
god it's been years it's been flip
ticking years I'm so far away from the
ship I can barely see it
good god it's been years how many
episodes is it been it's so friggin fun
and also using the camera at the top is
real nice but you know easy come easy go
splish oh oh and of course I get here
just in time for an eclipse well
actually that's pretty cool I guess I
can see that in the camera oh my god I
it's really pretty that's really cool I
mean I really like the fact that that's
possible in this game the whole Sun can
just be eclipsed out oh that's awesome
awesome awesome to the max hey I got a
dive back down mrs. Bai son
I'll see you never I guess but I got to
get back down because I'm now on the
surface again ah the familiar not sea
dragon roars oh it's so good to hear
from you again boy I almost ran India
geez hey sup how's it going how you
doing yeah remember me oh oh you're
looking oh yeah I'm a looker alright big
yellow must be Barry you know who it is
you know where to find me I got a during
some all right so I may be back on the
surface and I may be in the midst of
being all reminiscing and whatnot and I
know I have a quest I do I have a very
important quest with which I need to
accomplish to the best of my ability
even though I could die in the process
I'm very brave I indeed I am I know I'm
brave but there's one more thing to
explore while we're here so what we're
looking for is the new biome called the
crag fields now the crag fields are
located quite conveniently right behind
the Aurora's wreckage right to the south
of the engines if that is south I
believe the Aurora is pointed north can
never be too sure unless you build a
compass and I'm not going to waste
resources building that why would I but
down there is the crag field and
supposedly the crag fields are some of
the most resource abundant things that
you could possibly hope for which means
that's going to be good for me for
restocking and getting down into the
depths but before I even do that I need
to make sure I have all the tools
necessary to deal with an angry neighbor
such that as the sea dragon which means
I need guns upgrade space material every
other possible thing you could hope for
I'm going to lilo
I'm going to load my Cyclops up to the
nips with every resource I could
possibly gather and only then and only
then I'm prepared to go back down but
that's for another day but we're not
done yet
we got hello I'm in the middle of a very
important progress report and you're
just doing backflips on the surface
what's wrong with you where you going
what hell are you doing okay might I
also add that you look much bigger than
the other reef backs I've ever seen no
literally you're like the biggest reef
back I've ever seen in my goddamn life
you're you're like flip dick and huge
don't look at me like that don't look at
me like that
okay all right seriously you make big
box Barry look like petite box petunia
Jesus but anyway we got to get down here
we got to do some [ __ ] so let's do this
[ __ ] bo
hey there you are I've been looking all
over for you I got a few bones to pick
with you but maybe you can just carry on
your way hey I discovered who I'm
literally eats you for breakfast and as
a name rhymes with P blagging hey how
you doing there
you good you've been okay without me
just scared little baby all go that's
because I'm talking big inside the shell
doesn't mean that I want you to come
anywhere near me so how about you just f
off and go away thank you
oh if I'm not mistaken that's a crag now
I'm not an expert on what a crag is but
find a guess whoo
I'd say that these peculiar outcroppings
just jutting up from the ground as such
as this
it might be a bit of a craggy feel which
means that I'm sorry which means that
I'm in the midst of some of the most
resource abundant locations in the game
and that is quite obviously true
considering I see nothing but titanium
everywhere you look oh it's a thing of
beauty but there's a lot of bone sharks
around here so I'm gonna have to take
mr. pittsir out but first before I do
that I gotta take care of some uninvited
guests some people who don't belong here
well no your time was coming Lester oh
you think you can hide for me Lister yes
okay that's sir can you help me hide God
you are red and swollen with energy get
off my goddamn boat Oh No it's fused
permanently can you aha found your weak
time huh huh how'd you even stay here
how'd you even get around here huh oh we
got another freeloader can you um kindly
get the fudge away how about you don't
the other one got so swollen it just
exploded the second it tried to eat
that's right you go Anna is my territory
you can't stop me from getting what's
mine and it's all mine now that's a lot
of [ __ ] okay so we're in the crag field
which means that we need to go out there
and get what's ours and there's a whole
lot of it that's waiting just to be got
alright let's do this let's do this I
guess I can put this blue artifact away
that might be intelligent before I
actually go out there and die and lose
all my [ __ ]
I'll keep composter you've been keeping
me calm throughout the entire to give
it's crazy journey oh thank you for
being there in the dark times and the
light you through guys don't think I've
forgotten about how you guys have been
helping me all this way I know it hasn't
been an easy journey also I know that
now I can actually make lithium ion
batteries and I totally forgot about
that that's in one of those ah those are
tiger plants hey I'm gonna get you I'm
gonna get you oh I'm gonna get you oh
don't worry I'm gonna get you can you
even hurt this thing
I bet I can hurt you I want your seeds
try me try me try me come on try me oh
well I didn't work
alright then whatever I'll try it later
oh whoa whoa hey wow wow what are you
doing hey what are you doing what are
you doing what are you doing hey hey you
want to get ground or are you about to
get ground all your pads get ground
where'd you go where'd you go you trying
to escape from your grinding huh little
baby don't want to get ground oh no oh
no too late
hi that's all the warning you'll get oh
you guys got me far away from my boat
why did you do that I don't like this it
seems like a coordinated effort to bone
me over by bone sharks right Zack kids
don't even jive oh it's a bounty there's
so much titanium here this is endless
endless field of titanium hell to the
yeah a man is perfect is exactly what I
needed because if there's one thing I
need it's unlimited titanium and number
two I don't know Oh what is that what
the Frick is that what is that
what it's black I mean it's like oily oh
it's a big lithium that is not what I
expected that to be Wow
okay all right then I'm down I guess to
make more lithium ions power cells at
least after all right come on let's get
back here big box berry big blackberry
welcomed me into your bosom all right so
I'm gonna start from the bottom with
Aaron Lane B and then start slapping in
my titanium here hum guess that's all
that's going to take so I'm gonna get a
lot of this a whole lot of this I'm
going to do a bunch of farming between
this and the next episode but I'm in the
crag field baby which means that I got a
lot of work to do I got to gather up
literally everything and then I got to
take this to my other base get to
upgrades make some guns if I don't have
the patterns I gotta find them either
way got a lot of work left before I hang
my Keep Calm kiddy boats are down there
in the lava zone but it's going to
happen no matter what so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know how I'm doing down the comments
below and if you want to be put on a
locker again over which I am going to
have let me know down in the comments
and write something cool for me to look
at maybe some info maybe some
encouragement maybe a funny joke that
makes me laugh I'll take whatever you
got so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye-bye
[Music]